talk how did you guys end up
having jake paul pull up to the video
because we ran into him in hollywood
somewhere because was this right after
he knocked nick robinson out right yeah
it was like right after that so this is
before jake paul was like i mean he was
popping jake paul's always been popping
but i feel like he's in a different
spectrum of like being a serious boxer
now so like yeah talk about how that
happened you see you ran into him we ran
into him in hollywood and that's
probably why
but jay like he he likes solid i ain't
gonna lala i ain't even gonna put no
effect because he's like you know he had
to do that little [ __ ] he did like right
i mean
it's like it helps a win we helped him
he ain't really have to do it
to me but it was a win-win at the same
time he got to meet the baby play music
of course they probably nobody ever
heard
that [ __ ] can rap too for sure
like you're telling me jake paul can rap
i vouch brad it's good the music is good
how about she played us three songs that
i was like
really
and they're not in my head for sure i
ain't gonna lie to you like would you do
the jake paul feature
are you you go yeah but i fought with
jay paul so i would tell him like
like just take like life just a little
bit more serious you feel me
so if he hit you are you charging him or
you just gonna do it because it's mutual
i'm gonna do it when he charged us to do
like for no little appearance or nothing
he came and thug all day
he thugging with us all day
all day i think we went to the club
damn jake paul's got good music huh man
he played three good songs for sure i am
not i wonder if he's writing his own
[ __ ]
i only won't get to go in there
there's no way he's writing his [ __ ] i
definitely do you don't [ __ ] with jake
no no i just don't i just no i i respect
him i just don't think he's writing his
own music
i don't know all these i met a lot of
artists though they don't write those
[ __ ] for sure of course
i didn't even
if you're a youtuber you should pay
somebody to write your [ __ ] for sure you
know because if you want to be taken
serious you just can't assume your
shit's hot pay somebody who knows what
they're doing
he played a song i would like boy draco
hop on this [ __ ]
that's crazy i know he has a record with
gucci mane that's a few years old that
he bagged gucci out for
and this song was terrible there's a
gucci mane jake paul song that's like i
think it came out like 2018 or 2019.
that's crazy he probably always wanted
to be a rapper probably i mean i feel
like everyone right at some point in
time for sure
everybody
even everybody even but hey like a [ __ ]
act like man [ __ ] that rap [ __ ] i don't
need like he want them to be the biggest
ones yeah they be the ones that wish
they was
in
little baby or the baby's shoes
a hundred percent man 100